صافرات الانذار لا تهدا من صراخها في كل
مكان ورئيس البلاد يعلن بنفسه حاله
الطوارئ وحضر التجوال ابقوا جميعا في
بيوتكم لا احد يغادر منزله الا للضروره
القصوى رائحه الخوف تنتشر في البلاد ولا
احد يدري الى اين ستسير الامور الشوارع قد
تغرق بالدماء ومن يخرج دون داع لا يلومن
الا نفسه هو ليس تسربا اشعاعيا او حربا مع
بلد اخر فقط اصبح في حرا طليقا لا يا
عزيزي ليس فيتو الامم المتحده بل هو خوسي
ديلفو ماسياس والشهير بفيتو زعيم اخطر
عصابه دوليه في امريكا الجنوبيه حتى وصفه
البعض بانه خليفه بابلو اسكوبار اخطر مجرم
في التاريخ المتحدث باسم حكومه الاكوادور
بورتو ايزور لقد فر فيتو من سجنه قبل
ساعات من عمليه للشرطه في السجن وتم نشر
اكبر عدد من القوات للبحث عن هذا السجين
الخطر جدا